no inside few investors come car tester
tanju gench says the first Ford Mustang
hit us streets in 1964 and went on to
become an icon now half a century later
German customers can finally order one
directly from Ford not just through
importers tanju is sure his colleagues
are jealous that he's getting to test
this special car listen to that sound he
says he thinks it's wonderful and so
does andre and he's not just horsing
around and Drake takes advantage of the
opportunity to put the Mustang with its
five-liter v8 engine through its paces
yeah good he laments that American cars
generally answer good on curves but
Andrew says the Mustang rounds this one
without a problem the cars built for
sporty driving on curves and on
straightaways yes national 50 guarding
aboard the rocker switch is in the
center console allow you to adjust the
steering as well as the responsiveness
of the engine the Mustang lets drivers
choose between a sporty ride or a more
comfortable one while he knows that
tanju must be chomping at the bit to get
his pony car back andre still wants to
hold on to the reins a while longer
and the Mustang is certainly priced
right at just forty thousand euros in
Germany it's the only car with a v8
engine to be had for that amount and
that price includes almost everything
the leather steering wheel climate
control and the sink to voice-activated
infotainment system so there are few
optional extras available in contrast at
299 g/km the car produces a lot of co2
emissions
oh one meanwhile Sanju is reading the
mustang GT press kit and he's impressed
with its 5 liters of cubic capacity the
v8 engine generates a whopping 530
newton meters of torque sending the car
to a top speed of 250 kilometres an hour
it must be fun to drive ithaca with
Andre who is driving it says that at
engine speeds of up to 3,000 rpms the
Mustang cruises along but exceeds 3,000
rpms and it's like you're riding a horse
on steroids racing through the Prairie
with 417 other wild horses urging you on
fear did you ain't on a phone impression
as of the shouting Andrew says the
Mustangs transmission is also something
else dear ship travel is nice and short
but also pretty not cheap you really
have to put some muscle into switching
gears he says that in any other car
that'd be a big miners spit here it's
fitting as it makes you feel that the
Mustangs are car for really tough men
and women for their Mustang it's an
ultra steinhardt a minute of corner
start the Mustangs design has changed
greatly over the years but now Ford has
gone back to the roots Dalai estimates
done Andrew says the first Mustang had
an iconic design in recent years Ford
has revived it to great success it's
immediately recognizable even two kids
he thinks Ford has done such a good job
with the new model that it merits a
closer look the Mustang was named after
the p-51 Mustang fighter plane still it
was the galloping wild horse that became
the American sports cars emblem although
originally conceived as a woman's car
the Mustang has developed into a model
that fascinates men and women alike this
fastback coupe a in particular really
turns heads
inside apart from the occasional bit of
leather the trim is made of plastic
rather than aluminium buyers who want
real leather Recaro bucket seats will
need to shell out 1800 euros more hit
the start button and the powerful v8
springs to life
missed and I almost forgot his bags he
says GT stands for Gran Turismo a car
suitable for long trips and in spite of
its fastback shape the Mustang can hold
lots of cargo kiddo I [ __ ] lane so
what's his overall impression of the car
yeah gold eyes open he says with its v8
engine the Mustang isn't a car for
sensible drivers this test cart guzzled
16 liters of fuel per 100 kilometers no
wonder was such a huge engine but you
get that great sound the farmer john de
vivre that the Mustang gives you all for
a super basement price it's madness you
can't imagine anyone not having fun in
this car except when you need to fill up
the tank which reminds him for tank
Stella Apple for tanks Taylor being the
nice guy he is Android brings the
Mustang back to tangu without disrupting
his beauty sleep maybe now is the time
to mention that the Mustang is also
available with a 4-cylinder EcoBoost
engine which reduces fuel consumption to
eight liters per 100 kilometers oh those
are endless now that the Mustangs back
beginning tanju is thrilled that he can
finally start his test drive
he's ready to roll but unfortunately the
gas tanks empty introducing BMW sixth
generation seven series it's due to hit
showroom floors this autumn
in this vehicle class evolution rather
than revolution is the name of the game
that said there are some obvious
innovations in the design any new model
inevitably boasts a few technical
novelties in this case they include
laser and LED lighting and aerodynamic
air intakes
production has also been revamped in
recent years lightweight engineering and
design is ubiquitous in the car industry
not least because it helps reduce carbon
emissions but it comes in various shapes
and sizes varying from one car maker to
another high tensile steel aluminium and
plastic parts have become fairly
standard but BMW is going one step
further with its new seven series thanks
to new methods carbon fiber body parts
can now be manufactured for large-scale
production not just the visible parts
are made of costly carbon fiber as with
the i8 this time it also features in the
chassis even though it's out of sight
yeah Harold Kruger from BMW explains
that over half a billion euros was
invested in these new technologies over
the last three years the plant in dingle
thing has been refining manufacturing
and its competence in making superior
series makes it an ideal place to
produce the 7-series the lightweight
construction isn't just environmentally
friendly it also enhances the driving
experience there's less centrifugal
force around bends which combined with
intelligent construction makes the new
seventh series almost as agile as the
3-series but a lot more luxurious
the interior also features innovative
technology it's super user friendly
maximising comfort in the back seat is a
built-in tablet holder hit a button and
you can remove it and take it with you
when you slot it back in it's
automatically secured this allows you to
control all the main driving functions
as well as the in-car entertainment
system the seats in the back can of
course be adjusted
yeah as Klaus foolish explains further
highlights include semi autonomous
driving technology for speeds of up to
210 km/h remote-controlled parking
world-first and efficient dynamics
ceramics Moya highlights but in for
portion of burning fossil fuel
consumption for the plug-in hybrid BMW
740 II is rated at 2.1 liters per 100
kilometers with co2 emissions of 49
grams per kilometer as with its
predecessor the new seven series comes
with a choice of two wheelbases it's
also available with all-wheel drive the
3-litre diesel version of the new Beemer
will set you back 82 thousand euros the
750li starts at one hundred and thirteen
thousand euros in Germany the frills
cost extra needless to say
from the glk the GLC is born the sadies
introduces the second generation of its
mid-range SUV which is based on the seat
class platform the new version is by far
more spacious than its predecessor and
has a smoother less angular exterior for
now there are two diesel engines and one
gasoline-powered engine to choose from
but a hybrid version has been announced
following on from the coleus renault
makes a return to the SUV market with
the new Kjar it shares a platform with
the Nissan Qashqai but even on close
inspection you won't find many
similarities aside from the technology
initially there's a 96 kilowatt
gasoline-powered engine and two diesel
engines available in Germany the car
starts at 20,000 euros
see at has given the ether a major
facelift the main upgrades include new
engines different customization options
and extra safety features including a
fatigue warning multi collision brakes
and a brand-new connectivity and
infotainment system the chassis has also
been redesigned for extra comfort
ala Gordon thing isn't our car tester
explains how the three-cylinder engine
makes the sea at it be that extra sporty
and more efficient as they say all good
things come in threes the new gasoline
engine has one liter displacement and is
available in various power outputs the
model we're testing is the 6-speed
manual eco TSI turbo but it's also
available in a 7-speed direct-shift
version
the three cooling circuits cut emissions
significantly during the warm-up phase
with a consumption of 4.3 liters of fuel
400 kilometers the top speed is nearly
200 km/h
Dylan Reinhardt finds the three-cylinder
engine a little rough on startup but it
becomes more sporty and efficient once
against going he finds the newab ether
much more comfortable
as onsen is also very impressed with the
connectivity options and how quick and
easy it is to connect a smartphone to
the card so far in Kolkata smartphones
and infotainment systems can be
connected via USB the mirror link
feature transfers your smartphone's
interface to the touch screen and also
displays the functions of apple carplay
or android auto the car also has a new
gesture recognition feature which was
exclusively developed in partnership
with samsung using simple finger
movements you can make calls from your
smartphone and access various other
functions as well as information about
the car and fuel consumption of your
recent drives the new abita still has
the same soft dynamic exterior design
but the headlights now have LED daytime
running lights and although the shape is
unchanged you can now choose from
various color packs which add colorful
accents to the radiator grille mirrors
and wheel rims this is the red version
but this add-on also comes in bronze
purple grey black and white and will set
you back around 800 euros the colored
wheel rims make up the bulk of the cost
but may really make a difference
fun fun is it that meets our car tester
says the LED headlights make the abhi
thurs front resemble that of the larger
seattle leon but otherwise it's only
really the interior which has been
revamped with the new dashboard new
seats and connectivity features
connectivity it dadash kanda a beautiful
the abbey thurs interior upgrade also
includes a new display unit and the
steering wheel from big brother Leon you
can also use a color pack to brighten up
the interior with its new technology
color options and internet features siad
has made the abita a favorite especially
with young buyers
so
the 1955 suzu light the first car Suzuki
ever made the company had started in
1909 as a loon manufacturer by 1936
Suzuki moved from shuttling warp and
wool to shuttling people but first on
motorized bicycles and nearly 20 years
later with Japan's own version of the
people's car another 20 years later
Suzuki first ventured into the German
car market non-selective car testers
ashik nap explains that Suzuki debuted
on the German market in 1980 with it's
LJ 80 today it may seem a bit rustic and
tight he describes the transmission is
more adventurous than convenient but
that's all changed now when suzuki roll
off its first off-roader in 1970 the
brand was only known in germany as a
motorcycle that swiftly changed with the
development of the top-selling LJ model
line
won't here comes the LJ a crazy
reasonable fun economical and cutest car
in the world the LJ is the cross country
vehicle for city driving and the city
car for cross country driving originally
developed for military use the LJ hits
Germany's roads as an all-wheel-drive
multi-purpose car at a sensationally low
price umpires have lunch rush wanted a
yag macalinski explains that suzuki
entered the German market with a little
all-terrain vehicle the LJ 80 it's 12
and a half thousand deutsche mark list
price made all wheel drive affordable
for everyone soon after came the first
mini cars the alto and the Swift now
there's a broad range of mini cars
compacts and all wheel drive vehicles
the Alto was small but still spacious in
1981 with a three cylinder engine and
some unexpected extras it started
carving out a comfortable market niche
buyers of Suzuki's two-seat micro
convertible cappuccinos had to act fast
only 120 were offered on the German
market starting in 1994 back in Japan
the ultralight mini roadsters had
already been a favorite with young and
dynamic fun seekers for three years
suzuki also proved a trendsetter for
micro vans launching their worldwide
automotive exports in 1960 with the
carry it's one point eighty six metre
inside height enough for a tall man to
stand straight made it a hit with
handymen and tradespeople of all kinds
as of envy at gaza turkish place yoke
says when people think of suzuki
all-wheel drive has a prominent place so
they intend to keep producing vehicles
of this kind for example the IM for
concept car Suzuki's just premiered at
the geneva motor show it'll be appearing
on the german market in the foreseeable
future it's another subcompact sporting
all-wheel drive there's also the new
vitara with intelligent all-wheel drive
there's a type suitable for every
driving situation and suzuki intends to
continue their development your hands
are comfortably Demi target / acknow
points out that the vitara has little in
common with the LJ 80 but that can be a
good thing it's more spacious the
transmission is a dream and the
workmanship is far better and up-to-date
so he sees a bright future for Suzuki
especially for its all-wheel drive cars
and vans want that's pretending awesome
/ provide
italy's concorso d'eleganza villa desta
is one of the world's oldest and most
exclusive classic car events with the
number of entries strictly limited it
represents a gathering of the automotive
creme de la creme the participants were
chosen from among thousands of
applicants taking part in the concourse
of vastly enhances both the owner's
personal prestige and their vehicles
market value
hazuki fantastic later Mulder describes
the atmosphere of the villa desta as
utterly fantastic that in combination
all the cars from the various groups
makes this without a doubt one of the
International vintage car highlights
sika height food in highlights felt
right does it fit juan felipe garcia
adds that this is one of the premier
vintage car events in an incredible
location location in italy / and
globally every year main sponsor BMW
brings along an exhibit on the company's
own history the focus this year is on
BMW art cars touring cars painted by
renowned artists the striking color
scheme of this 1979 BMW m1 is an Andy
Warhol original
ever since I much to BMWs yahan near
posh recalls that he and his teammates
achieved great success driving touring
cars in races like the 24 hour of
Lamoure but they stood little chance of
placing in a touring car because the
sports car prototypes at the mall was so
much faster with a factory entry they
couldn't hope for any more than winning
best in class and after a while that
wasn't enough then her vehicle at came
up with the idea of having artist
designed touring car paint jobs they
went for it because it gave them
something else to focus on when I know
could sluggish road mr. Larson VAR d ed
films waiting for Santos team going to
have ever done under half garbage
Toronto this BMW 320i was done by roy
lichtenstein in 1977 this elaborately
painted BMW 3.0 CSL was created by frank
stella in 76 every art car saw active
service on the track the very first art
car was the three-point o CSL alexander
calder designed in 1975
in the 1970s the three-point OCS l
street version was a dream reserved for
the very few now as a tribute to this
icon of automotive design BMW has
created the 3.0 CSL homage unfortunately
the concept car never made it to volume
production
back to the past or at least the cars of
the past
this 1933 pierce-arrow has a very
special history the air than me HD ken
allen awkward arnold carve lat says
older people like him remember Hollywood
legend Clark Gable who's actress wife
was the first buyer of a pierce-arrow
the car maker was the first to integrate
the headlights into the body and it
introduced the very first automatic door
lock system there's only one lock neatly
covered the interior boasts a comfort
people today can hardly imagine the
engine had a 7.5 liter capacity giving
it incredible talk PS arrows what also
the first with a freewheeling
transmission which made driving much
easier last month indeed ciety last man
here for you give up my shutter on
dammit feared as it were no bar the
concorso d'eleganza on Lake Como is the
premier event for everyone who's anyone
in vintage car circles it's also a
perfect opportunity to revel in
nostalgia for as the name suggests the
elegance of eras past when every model
was a work of art and for the days of
dirt cheap fuel for a time before the
wind tunnel normed all body styles from
luxury to economy classes
the concourse I'll reaches a climax in
the awards ceremony a prize for the
winner among winners this year the owner
of this 1950 Ferrari 166 mm can take the
coveted copper door or villa d'este
their home to Britain
I'm not very good at showing my emotions
but certainly my wife was very happy and
she did show her emotions world but I am
very very pleased I'm very honored and I
know it's a privilege